okay hi everyone welcome to
another episode of science and
technology q a for
kids and others so let me see what
interesting questions there are that
have accumulated i think we have some
left over from last time maybe we'll
start with those
uh okay i see one here from jack
why is there a size limit for planetary
bodies in the universe is the size of
jupiter the largest that is possible
okay so interesting question
so things the size of the sun
uh become stars things the size of
jupiter
stay as planets what makes that
difference
and is it always does it always have to
be that way
what what is a star a star
is something that has lots of nuclear
reactions going on
what's happening inside the sun for
example is that
there's enough the
the things are being sort of pulled
together enough that
for example hydrogen atoms that
uh actually that there that just the
protons the nuclei of hydrogen atoms
are being kind of pulled together hard
enough that
the protons can merge and release a lot
of energy
through a nuclear reaction so normally
two protons they both have charge plus
one
the sort of rule for electricity is like
charges repel
so that means protons are being pushed
apart
by electrical forces in order to get the
protons to
actually crash into each other you need
to give them lots of energy
that they're so that they can overcome
the force of repulsion associated with
their electrical charges
well in something like the sun there's
the sun is hot enough
that those uh for example the center of
the sun is about 10 million degrees
centigrade
it's hot enough that what what
temperature what temperature means is
that
tells you the the average energy of
each of the individual particles and so
at 10 million degrees
you're absolutely hot enough that two
protons
can be going fast enough that they
overcome that that energy barrier
associated with electrical repulsion and
they crash into each other what happens
when they crash into each other
well then the strong nuclear force takes
over
the force that will bind nuclei together
the force that causes one
to be able to have lots of protons and
neutrons bound together
in the nuclei of heavier elements that
force takes over
when you get within uh well 10 to the
minus 15 meters roughly
um let's see one what is that a million
uh a millionth billionth of a meter
uh when you get to that distance which
is about the size of a proton
when when things like protons get that
close together
there's a very strong force of
attraction between them which will bind
them together and that's how we
come to have atomic nuclei from helium
uh lithium beryllium boron so on down
the periodic table
that have many protons in them even
though the protons
are repelling each other through
electrical forces they're being pulled
together by the strong nuclear force
so what's happening is something
something like the sun
is that protons mostly are being
uh uh made to go fast enough
that they overcome the the repulsion
associated electrical forces
they can kind of uh they get collide
together
the strong nuclear force takes over what
does that strong nuclear force lead to
it causes those protons to be combined
into something which might eventually
turn into a
helium nucleus for example and it turns
out that when
when they bind together they release
energy and that's the energy of nuclear
fusion
and that's the energy that powers the
sun and powers all stars
and so essentially when when you have
things like protons that are able to be
sort of pushed together
hard enough they will undergo nuclear
fusion
the nuclear fusion will generate lots of
energy and
uh that is what uh that's what makes
a star go now it's a little bit
complicated because there are a couple
of different things
going on so one question is how do the
protons get sort of pushed together
enough that they undergo nuclear fusion
in the first place
well the main force that does that is
the force of gravity
that's the force that is kind of making
the the sort of pulling the pieces of
the star together
now what happens is that uh
once once the things are sort of
squashed together enough
that nuclear fusion can occur then they
start generating energy
then the temperature goes up then the
things start going fast
and that allows fusion to happen in
different ways so let me try and unpack
that
it's a little bit complicated so
one way that the the primary thing is
can you get electro
that can get protons to collide and
and undergo nuclear fusion so one way to
do that might be
you just take all those protons and you
put them in a big box
and you just squash the box and you just
put huge amounts of pressure on this box
and just push these these uh these
protons together
that will be one way to get the protons
to get so close
that they can undergo nuclear fusion
that's sort of way number one
way number two is you don't do that but
just have these protons running around
fast enough that two of them just
randomly if they're if they're on a
collision course for each other
they will not deflect as a result of
electrical forces
they'll just successfully collide and if
they're going with enough momentum
that will happen so there's a two
different ways in which you can kind of
get those protons to be sort of squashed
together
to the point where nuclear fusion can
happen so
once you have a star going the star
is producing nuclear fusion that's
producing
energy that's making the the protons and
other things in the star have high
energy
that's causing them to be able to just
by virtue of their energy that kinetic
energy
to be able to overcome this this
potential barrier associated with
electrical repulsion
and undergo nuclear fusion that's that's
one mechanism
for uh for having having that happen
the other mechanism is just that you're
squashing things together so what
basically happens when stars form
is matter starts getting
pulled in by the force of gravity and at
some point
it gets pulled in hard enough that
essentially protons
end up starting to uh to collide
together
get close enough that nuclear forces can
can start working
and then at that point as soon as
nuclear forces start working the thing
essentially lights up and becomes a star
because you've squashed enough protons
together that they can
uh produce energy that they'll enough
fusion is happening you produce energy
you heat the thing up the thing becomes
a star so first of all there's sort of
com
compression through gravitational forces
then the thing
kind of uh heats up and and you're able
to to get
more uh fusion happening just by virtue
of the energy of all the particles
running around inside the star
so the question is at what size of
object
is there a kind of enough squashing due
to gravity that you can get it to kind
of
undergo nuclear fusion and kind of light
up like that and the answer is it's
somewhere between the size of jupiter
and the size of the sun
the sun is actually actually a
comparatively large star
there are stars much much larger than
the sun um both
stars larger in terms of their their
mass
and larger much larger in terms of their
size for example a star like betelgeuse
is a red giant star it's a comparatively
cold star
but its size is in our solar system it
would reach about out to the orbit of
jupiter
so it's a huge star it's the rather
diffuse star it doesn't have a
particularly high mass
it's larger than the sun but not
outrageously so
but the sun is in the in the spectrum of
stars is a comparatively
you know it's it's a it's a decently
large star
um there are stars that are a tenth of
its mass maybe less than that
um as you go down there's i'm not
exactly sure what the cutoff is maybe um
oh i don't know maybe five percent the
mass of the sun something like that
maybe a little bit more than that
at which uh below that mass you just end
up with things like jupiter planet-like
things
you do not get enough force of gravity
to start nuclear fusion to start the
thing behaving like a star
and um the uh
thing it's again a little bit
complicated because the extent to which
nuclear fusion can happen
and exactly what all the barriers to
nuclear fusion are and so on
depend on what what emma elements
exist in the star so for example in the
sun
the primary thing that is burning in the
sun is hydrogen
um turning into uh into helium but as
the
star gets older it might have used up
most of its hydrogen
it will have turned it into heavier
elements and then those will have to
uh be combined together and among other
things
the uh the the electrical repulsion
of a heavier nucleus with more protons
in it is larger
than the electrical repulsion uh for for
hydrogen so different things happen
when a star has a supernova
what's happening is that it has it has
the the star is kind of um uh
there's a force of gravity that's that's
causing the star to be pulled
in and there's a force that's associated
with
the the temperature of the components of
the star that's sort of pushing the star
out and what ends up happening in a
supernova
is that the the the force pushing the
star out
can no longer you've kind of burnt it
through enough of the fuel
in effect that the force pushing the
star out can no longer overcome the
force of gravity the thing contracts
it does so rather rapidly as it
contracts
uh new kinds of nuclear fusions start up
so for example
uh elements like silicon and oxygen um
they it starts to be the case there's
enough force of contraction
that it uh can cause the the
again i'm i'm kind of i'm kind of trying
to simplify several things here
um but basically can can get to the
point where
where those nuclei which have higher
charge and sort of take more effort
to to um to cause to collide together
they can start colliding when they start
colliding that releases a lot of energy
and that all happens rather suddenly and
so in a matter of uh
seconds to minutes or something the star
will explode
dramatically and uh we'll see this um
uh you know a supernova happens probably
in our galaxy once every
millennium and uh it will uh light up
the night sky for a few days and things
like that
last one that we know about that was
visible from the earth um
in a dramatic way happened in 10 54 a.d
and it left over the crab nebula but
um so the the answer to the original
question about
um uh about sort of jupiter-sized things
is yes
they'll stay as planet-like things they
will not light up the stars
there's a critical size at which the
force of gravity will cause the thing to
kind of
uh compress itself start nuclear fusion
light up as a star
that critical um size uh depends
on the constituents depends on whether
it's mostly hydrogen or whether it has
heavier elements in it
um so you can have sort of a thing
a jupiter-like thing that hasn't started
off as a star
or one that has depending on what
constituents it has in it
and the question of how many sort of
things that are sort of jupiter-like
objects are just sort of floating around
the universe
it's not really clear what the answer to
that is it's not clear
whether there's a distribution of
star-like things that goes down to quite
small sizes
um that just aren't lit up as stars
or whether there's sort of a cut off to
how big the um the things that are sort
of
independently floating around the galaxy
might be i mean the other thing to
realize is
that solar systems most stars are one
didn't know that until fairly recently
but it's it's clear that
most stars form planets when the stars
form
the stars form as a as a sort of they're
pulled together by the force of gravity
they'll typically form an accretion disk
they'll form this
this disc around the star that is um
kind of a flattened area
uh the thing is rotating around a sort
of this flattened amount of material
and that that material will gradually
clump together and we'll form planets
and for a star the size of the sun we'd
expect
ten ish planets to form from from what
we now know
and it's not clear what happens in the
history of a solar system
what happens to those planets how many
planets that originally form
are kept in stable orbits in the solar
system
how many of them are ejected out of the
solar system how many might crash into
each other
and so on so for example in our solar
system the asteroid belt mostly between
the orbits of mars and jupiter
um is a lot of uh a lot of sort of small
things that
probably came from the collision of
planets early in the in the history of
the solar system
and the question of how many lost
planets there were from our solar system
we don't know the answer to that we
don't know uh
even probably as as comparatively
recently
as the time of the dinosaurs we don't
really know
uh what other configuration of planets
might have existed in our solar system
um and uh so it could be that our solar
system had an extra three or four big
planets
and they've they're off floating through
space somewhere
as things which are not big enough to
make stars
um but they exist as as cold
uh solid objects uh floating through
through the um through the galaxy
um and we've seen fairly recently it
wasn't
known whether there were an interstellar
asteroid so to speak whether there were
things like
asteroids that had escaped from another
solar system and were sort of
free-floating in the galaxy um we now
know that those do exist one was
observed or maybe two or three years ago
now
uh uma numero i think was its name if i
pronounce it correctly
um and you could kind of tell that it
was a
an extrasolar asteroid um because
it when you trace its its trajectory you
could see that it wasn't a trajectory
that would cause it
to actually successfully orbit the sun
it had to be something that wasn't in
orbit around the sun that was coming
from elsewhere in the galaxy
and so that's um there's probably lots
of rock-like stuff
floating around the galaxy uh one of the
questions is is it big enough
that when it passes in front of a star
that it will make the star the
light from the stars go down that's the
way
that's one of the methods for detecting
um exoplanets planets around other stars
it's just seeing as the star as the
planet goes in front of that other star
that you're observing
the amount of light coming from that of
the star will dip slightly
and if you see the light from the star
repeatedly dipping
you know every hundred days or something
then a good explanation for that is oh
there's a planet
that's going around that star and every
hundred days
it's uh it's blocking some of the light
from that star that's one of the methods
for detecting
uh exoplanets and so one might think
that something like that might happen
for for just random planets such as sort
of free-floating through the galaxy but
it's much harder to detect that because
while you can kind of say oh well my
telescope might have drifted a bit
but i'm seeing a signal every 100 days
something happens precisely every 100
days
that's much easier to detect than just
oh something went in front of my
star was it something that went in front
of the star or was it some
you know glitch if it was a telescope on
the surface of the earth was it some
piece of cloud you know high in the
atmosphere or something
that got in front of the star only if
it's this repeated thing is it
easier to do the experiment to find out
that it's really something associated
with the star
okay there's a question here about um
from jimmy about what happens to the
electrons before fusion in the sun
occurs okay so here's the thing
when when you have a hydrogen atom
hydrogen atom has a proton in its
nucleus uh most hydrogen atoms have just
one proton in the nucleus
the other isotopes of hydrogen like
deuterium has a proton and a neutron in
its nucleus
but basically it's a proton in the
nucleus and there's a
an electron that's kind of going around
the nucleus it's it's kind of uh
quantum mechanics says that this picture
of it sort of just going around
isn't quite right but it's a it's a very
good way to think about it is the
electronics are
going around the nucleus the thing to
understand is
the the distance the average distance
that the electron is from the nucleus
is a hundred thousand times the size of
the nucleus
so in a sense the nucleus is this little
lump in the middle
and there's sort of empty emptiness out
to
the average distance that the electron
is is about a hundred thousand times
the size of the nucleus which in this
case is just a single proton
so the the um what causes
the electron to kind of stay uh kind of
hanging out with the proton well it's a
force of electrical attraction
the the electron is negatively charged
the proton is positively charged
so the rule is unlike charges attract
so there's a force of electrical
attraction between those things
okay now as you as you put
more energy into the atom by for example
uh heating it by by having heating it up
by having it to bump into other atoms
things like that
as you put more energy in what will
happen roughly
is that the electron will get just a
little bit further away from the nucleus
and in quantum mechanics it's a bit of a
more complicated story but the average
distance
that the electron is from the nucleus
will increase slightly
okay well there comes a point uh very
precisely it's a 13.6
electron volts where you put
enough energy into the electron that
actually
that energy is enough to have it escape
from the proton so it's a little bit
like the following when
if you're on the earth and you fire a
rocket into space
you need the rocket to have a certain
amount of energy
it turns out to be going at a certain
speed
so if you want the rocket to escape from
the earth it has to be going in the case
of the earth at 25
000 miles an hour at that speed the
kinetic energy
of the rocket will exceed the energy
associated with the gravitational uh
pull of the earth
and it's the same kind of thing with an
electron and a proton in a hydrogen atom
when the electron is given enough energy
it will escape from the proton and so
that process is called ionization
it will turn the the hydrogen atom into
a hydrogen ion
which is just a proton um and the
electron will then be
be ripped out of the um uh
of the of the hydrogen atom and it will
be uh
uh then free to to do its own thing
so for example we we are commonly see
when when you have
hydrogen gas for example that has been
ionized
that's what we see it's not necessarily
hydrogen gas it will be other gases
when you see fire for example um that is
an example of an
ionized a plasma in which atoms have
been ionized or at least partly ionized
in the sense that their electrons have
been ripped out of the atom
um and are sort of freely floating
around so in the case of the sun
um as the temperature increases the uh
the electrons will be ripped out of
their
um uh their their atoms
and um the uh um
and and they'll just be the electrons
are just freely floating around in the
sun
and um the the thing that um uh
you know you might ask what happens when
the electrons collide
that's a much less in let's well
that process uh primarily only involves
electromagnetic interactions it there's
no when when two electrons crash
together
there is no known process by which the
electrons can kind of
merge into something like an atomic
nucleus there's no
analog of the strong nuclear force that
binds nuclei together so you can have
collections of protons and neutrons and
so on those are
so-called strongly interacting particles
that combine together into atomic nuclei
but for electrons nothing like that
happens for electrons
the only force uh between electrons
is an electrical force there's actually
other forces there's thing called the
weak
nuclear force which also operates um
that has to do with neutrinos and things
as well
um but there's no way to make kind of a
um uh sort of a a nucleus made of
electrons or something
there is if you have an electron and a
positron positron is the anti-particle
of the electron
you can make a little positronium atom
that is about the size of a hydrogen
atom actually
that consists of an electron where
instead of it having as its nucleus so
to speak a proton it has a positron
but that's not something that's tightly
bound like an atomic nucleus
and and so far as we know that there
simply isn't
um a way to um to have electrons
interact strongly like that now
whether uh it will turn out to be the
case
well so so the thing to understand is a
proton has a very definite size a proton
is about 10 to the minus 15 meters
across
uh a million billionth of a meter across
um an electron so far as we know
has no extent it's just like a perfect
geometrical point
actually we know only that it's smaller
than about
roughly a millionth the size of a proton
it's certainly smaller than a millionth
the size of the proton now in
in the fundamental theory of physics
that we've been developing
uh electrons actually do have a definite
size
um but their size is probably around 10
to the minus 80 meters
in our model so it's absolutely tiny
it's a you know
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillion the size of a proton or
something
and uh if that's that's right that
that's the correct size
then it would be the case that
sufficiently high energy electrons
if sort of fired each other could have
some some force uh associated with them
that is stronger than electro
electromagnetic force but you wouldn't
see that until you were using so much
energy
it's just unbelievably much more energy
than
than we know any process to produce in
the universe as it exists today
okay there's a question here
boy all kinds of physics questions here
all right it's a question here from
brian
why does it take uh
a long time for a photon to go from the
from the
uh core of the sun to the surface of the
sun but only eight minutes to reach the
earth so i think it takes
brian is saying a hundred thousand years
i thought it was a little bit longer
even to go from the center of the sun to
the surface of the sun
okay so here's how it works if a photon
is traveling through a vacuum through
empty space
it goes at the speed of light and the
speed of light
is it goes roughly a a billionth of a
um it takes a billionth of a second to
go one foot
it takes needless to say a year to go
one light year
it takes about eight minutes to go uh
the distance from the
sun to the earth in a vacuum so that's
kind of
the uh the fastest that a photon can go
now if you even have a photon in a piece
of glass
or water what's happening is
the photon is continually getting um
absorbed and re-emitted so there'll be a
piece of let's say
a water molecule and the photon will get
absorbed by that by well atoms in the
water molecule
um and it'll get absorbed
it'll cause the electrons in those atoms
to increase that energy and the
electrons will then decrease their
energy again
and emit a photon again and there's a
delay when that happens
so photon comes in it's absorbed by an
atom
atom then decays and re-emits the photon
but there's a slight delay and that
delay is what causes light to travel at
a slower speed
in something like water or glass light
travels 1.33 times slower in water
than it does in the vacuum in air it
travels at very close to the speed it
does in a vacuum
in glass it's usually one and a half
times slower than um
than a vacuum in diamond it's 2.7 times
slower than a vacuum
and so on and so what's happening in all
these materials is
the photon is keeps on getting absorbed
re-emitted absorbed re-emitted every
time there's an absorption re-emission
event the photon is kind of slowed down
a bit
so in the case of the sun what's
happening is
there are zillions of uh
absorption re-emission events that are
happening and
the effective refractive index that's
the measure of the ratio of the speed of
the
of the photon in uh the vacuum as
compared to the
material um that is effectively some
very huge number
and so essentially a photon you can
think of the sun
as actually being very opaque the photon
just sort of gets to something
and then it it's it's uh it's it's being
absorbed remitted all the time
and that happens a zillion times in the
in the passage of the of the photon from
the center of the sun to the surface
and that's why it takes a long time
so let's see
um okay there's a question here
is there a way to reduce the energy of
an electron so it falls into the nucleus
okay that was a question people were
very keen to answer about 120 years ago
so the history of this was
atoms have been sort of thought about in
ancient greek times as maybe that's what
mata is made of
discrete atoms and so on but people
weren't very sure
by about 18 by the mid-1800s
people were pretty sure that atoms
existed and there were two basic lines
of evidence
one was when you do chemistry there are
all these ways in which you get exactly
twice
this amount of material as compared to
that and you can explain these numbers
these ratios
if things are made of discrete atoms
that's one line of developments
the other one was processes like
brownian motion so brownian motion
is was first observed by a chap called
brown needless to
say um it was a little pollen grain
um in in some water for example
and you could see through a microscope
the pollen grain was was
uh kicked discreetly kicked
moved around and those little kicks were
water molecules hitting the pollen grain
and moving it
and that process of sort of discrete
kicks
kind of told you there were discrete
things that
made up the water rather than it being
just this continuous fluid
right now people know that matter is
made of discrete things namely atoms
has sort of been a big question of
whether space is similarly made of
discrete things
i think our uh fundamental theory of
physics that we've developed over the
last year or so
makes it pretty clear that space is also
made of discrete stuff
although the size of those discrete
atoms of space
is unbelievably much smaller than the
size of things like material atoms
it's probably uh oh it's trillion
trillion trillion trillion chilling time
i should
be able to roll off my my counts of
trillions properly but but
it's of that multiple trillions of times
smaller
than the size of of atoms that we know
about so okay
mid-1800s people knew atoms existed what
were atoms made of
well a chap called ernest rutherford was
the one who figured out
that you could uh uh have particles
so-called alpha particles
actually helium nuclei and you could
fire them
at an atom and most of the time they
just go straight through
but just some small fraction of the time
they would be deflected through a large
angle
so it's as if most of the time they just
hit nothing in the atom
but just sometimes they hit some hard
bit in the atom and they're deflected a
lot
and that hard bit that they were hitting
in the atom is the atomic nucleus
and what became clear is that the atomic
nucleus had protons and then much later
neutrons got discovered and that
contains protons and neutrons
then the electron uh is electrons are
sort of
outside of the nucleus okay so
one of the first things that people
wondered was why didn't
why don't uh electrons just
uh lose energy and spiral into the
nucleus
so for example in um
uh in general when things are
sort of orbiting around through some
force of let's say
let's say things are being held in orbit
by the force of gravity
um so the the thing is going round and
you know centrifugal force effectively
is
is making the thing tend to try and get
out of its orbit why does that happen
well if left to its own devices uh
something will just keep going in a
uniform state of motion so if you
take something in space it has no forces
acting on it you
you throw it in some direction it'll
just keep going in that direction
forever
so if it's going to be kept in orbit you
have to have some force
that's pulling the thing that's
preventing it from just
going in a straight line that's causing
it to go in for example a circular orbit
so for example you might have a force of
gravity that's doing that that's how
uh you know planets orbit the sun and
things like this moons orbit
planets etc okay well
in order for the thing to keep going in
its orbit the
the planet has to have a certain amount
of energy if
the the the energy is what keeps it sort
of going around if it didn't have that
energy the force of gravity would
overtake it and it will be pulled in
to the wherever the gravity is coming
from the center of
of of gravitational attraction and the
you know the planet would just
lose energy and spiral in and crash into
the sun okay so
the reason that doesn't happen the
reason that's not happening to the earth
is the earth doesn't really have a way
to lose energy like that
at least not on a large scale now in the
case of
when you have black holes uh very
um they're very small you know a few
kilometers across perhaps less than a
kilometer across
uh intense things with masses
larger than the sun black holes uh
can orbit very close to each other and
they do actually have a way to lose
energy and that way of losing energy
is the emission of gravitational
radiation and so
black holes when they when they are
orbiting around each other they'll lose
energy through gravitational radiation
that will cause them to spiral in and
the black holes will get closer and
closer together
as they spiral in they'll go faster and
faster they'll lose more energy through
gravitational radiation
um and eventually they'll they'll lose
enough energy that they just collide
with each other
and that splat is a very dramatic event
and uh for example we can now detect
gravitational uh the gravitational
radiation
from black hole mergers that are
happening pretty much all the way across
the universe from us
uh for example they're ones that we've
seen that are from seven billion years
ago
in the last year or two um which means
that they're at least halfway across the
universe from us
so it's a very dramatic event when two
black holes finally sort of spiral in
um having lost energy through
gravitational radiation okay
so the question is why does that not
happen with electrons
when electrons and atoms um have uh
in order to keep the electron in its
orbit so to speak
you have to uh you have to have some
force of attraction that's an electrical
force of attraction
that will effectively accelerate the
electron because the electron
without any acceleration will just keep
going in a straight line so you have to
exert a force which causes acceleration
of the electron
and one of the rules about
electromagnetism is accelerated charges
produce electromagnetic radiation so for
example if you have
the antenna in your cell phone what's
happening in that antenna
is it's it's sort of more or less pieces
of wire uh and electrons are going back
and forth back and forth inside those
those pieces of wire and the
acceleration associated with the
electron going first one direction then
the other direction and so on
that acceleration causes the electron to
emit
an electromagnetic wave which is the
radio wave which is the thing that
allows your cell phone to communicate
with uh
with the outside world so one of the
rules about
charged particles is accelerated charged
particles radiate electromagnetic energy
okay so people knew that back in the
early 1900s
and so they said well so why is it the
case that electrons in atoms
don't radiate electromagnetic energy and
spiral into the nucleus and go splat
okay so why doesn't that happen well
the answer uh was um originally
uh has an answer that was partly
happened before quantum mechanics but
but basically the answer is it's just a
rule about physics
that energy is quantized in the sense in
in the case of an atom there are only a
limited enough
number of possible energy levels that
the electron can occupy
so to say the electron is just sort of
doing its happy
thing uh sort of going around the
nucleus of a hydrogen atom
okay all good it has a certain energy
you say
you can you kick it a bit you can give
it a higher energy and a higher energy
eventually the energy you can get up to
high enough energy that will escape from
the atomic nucleus
but they're a discrete set of those
energy levels actually if you
if you work it out in the theory of the
hydrogen atom the um
uh the nth level has an energy about uh
one over n
squared and so the the levels sort of
accumulate as you get up to
uh this critical energy level at which
point you get ionization
and the electron escapes from the atom
but so these energy levels are quantized
they're just a limited number of
possible energy levels for the electron
in the atom
so the way this is understood in quantum
mechanics
is basically a mathematical theory of
why that happens
it doesn't really explain quotes why
that happens
it's uh it's just a descriptive
mathematical model for what's going on
and the sort of key idea that comes up
in
what's sometimes called wave mechanics
uh it's
sometimes related to the schrodinger
equation which is sort of a key equation
in quantum mechanics
is roughly this one thinks of the
electron as being represented like a
wave
and if you think about something like a
piece of string
and you are sort of let's say the string
is like a violin string or something and
you're plucking the violin string
they'll be the string will have a
certain mode that it will go into so the
string will be
sort of uh it'll bow outwards in some
direction and then it'll come back
and down and keep vibrating in that way
that's one mode of the string another
mode of the string
is that it can go up and then down and
then
over like this so so in other words it's
it has sort of
two humps in it and or it can have three
humps
but if you fix the ends of the string to
always be
at a particular position there's a fixed
integer number of humps a whole number
of humps that the thing can have
so it can have just one hump two humps
three humps and so on
and those correspond when you're playing
a musical instrument
uh when you uh kind of pluck a string
you'll find that there's both the the
fundamental frequency that's kind of the
one hump version
and then there'll be the overtones the
harmonics
that correspond to these various
different uh uh
other numbers of humps effectively in in
the wave that's made by that string
so that's sort of the physical version
in strings the mathematics
of the so-called wave function of
electrons in hydrogen atoms
works the same way and the the
the setup is mathematically very similar
and um so what you end up finding is
that there are just these discrete
integer energy levels that are possible
for the electron
and that's what uh quantum mechanics
says
and so the reason the electron can't
just spiral into the nucleus is
how's it going to get there as it starts
spiraling it has to change its energy
but it can't change it continuously we'd
have to change it and jump
and it can't do that because it's it's
the the sort of gradual emission of
radiation doesn't work
the only way it can emit radiation is in
these is in these jumps where it goes
from one energy level to another energy
level
and the way you see that in in atoms
there are the so-called spectral lines
different elements have
characteristically different spectral
lines
the spectral lines are associated with
transitions from one energy level
of electrons to others and depending on
the exact structure of the atom
you'll have different transitions that
can occur and and those are that's what
for example
uh neon neon lights the the red of the
neon
is a particular energy level a
particular transition between two energy
levels in the neon atom
um that causes that red light to be
emitted it's a particular frequency of
photon
that's emitted as a result of a
particular transition in neon
or for example sodium lamps uh they they
there's a very particular uh the the
sodium lamps are the d
lines of sodium um that emit this kind
of orange light and it's a very specific
frequency of light that gets submitted
because of a transition between
two particular energy levels of
electrons and sodium atoms
so so the the kind of descriptive reason
why the electron can't just sort of
spiral into the nucleus is because the
energy levels
of the electron are quantized and so it
can't
it can't just sort of gradually spiral
in now you might ask
um how does that how does that really
work
what is what's really going on inside
and we're pretty close to being able to
answer that question
in our models um we don't uh let me
think for a second if there's a
way to try to explain this
um
i think we're not quite there yet in
terms of having a
really simple explanation of um
uh of quantization of energy in a in a
um
uh in a hydrogen atom but roughly
well um
yeah no come back in a couple of months
we'll we'll we we might have a cleaner
explanation by then
um i think the story i would tell now
has to do with these things called
multi-way systems
which are kind of a representation of of
multiple possible histories
for uh the the atom
and the way that there's kind of
interactions between those multiple
possible histories and so on
okay there's a question here boy we got
a lot of physics today
okay there's a question just came in
from jimmy asking how does one
solve more than one electron systems
well boy that's that's complicated so
the theory of the hydrogen atom uh in
quantum mechanics was worked out in the
1920s originally the basic theory
when when you have just uh one
when you have a point atomic nucleus and
you have an electron
then it's a pretty simple partial
differential equation
uh and you solve for the uh so-called
eigen modes of that partial differential
equation you get the answer
it's all good okay let's consider the
helium atom
the helium atom has a point nucleus and
has two electrons in it
nobody's ever found a nice mathematical
formula solution for the helium atom
you can do a computer simulation of a
helium atom
using the schrodinger equation and that
works really pretty well
um but in terms of is there a
mathematical function
that describes the helium atom well no
not quite
so just to to say how this works you
know people are familiar perhaps in
mathematics
with things like sines and cosines
exponentials and logarithms and so on
uh in mathematical physics over the last
150 years a couple hundred years
there's a whole zoo of other kinds of
so-called special functions
of mathematical physics that people have
invented
there's probably about maybe 200 of them
that are in common use
and what's important about these
functions is that
they solve certain kinds of equations
and they show up all over the place like
they're things called bessel functions
they were originally invented
as a result of studying things to do
with the motion of the moon but they
also show up and describing
the the shape of a drum head when a drum
is uh
when you kind of uh beat a drum and uh
the way that it um
it deforms um and vibrates and so on
they also show up in
a zillion other places so these special
functions
have this feature that you you invent
them once and they show up in lots of
places and that's why they're
they're useful uh so in the case of uh
the hydrogen atom
the hydrogen atoms can be solved uh the
there's just a
a a mathematical formula that describes
this wave function for the hydrogen atom
and solved in terms of two kinds of
special functions things called lager
polynomials
and things called spherical harmonics
and the lager polynomials are just
polynomials
i my memory is not good enough to be
able to recite the first through lager
polynomials
um the uh if you type them in to woven
language or mathematica you'll it'll
it'll be able to generate as many lager
polynomials as you could possibly want
but the lager polynomials
determine the uh the radial
um uh so this this wave function
it's a it's a function of the position
in the hydrogen atom and you usually
measure that by saying
the distance from the center of the
hydrogen atom as well as the angles
around from the center it's kind of like
saying distance from the center of the
earth
and then latitude and longitude on the
surface of the earth
so the radial function in the case of
the hydrogen atom is lager polynomials
and the the the functions that tell you
about the surface the angular functions
are these things called spherical
harmonics and um
the spherical harmonics are kind of
generalizations of sines and cosines
so sine and cosine represent kind of
functions that describe
uh kind of you know in trigonometry they
describe sort of the uh
the the the x and y coordinates
when you're just going around a circle
and you specify what the angle is and
that tells you the x
displacement and y displacement a
spherical harmonics are sort of a
generalization of special of
sines and cosines to work on spheres
rather than
on just on circles um and so the
spherical harmonics
uh have are the things that determine
the angular structure
and when you solve the hydrogen atom you
have these different energy levels
um they they were originally named um
originally german names
a lot of the stuff was was developed in
germany
in the 1920s and so on um and so there's
the
s orbital and the p orbital uh
uh s p d f g i think is the is the
sequence
um and uh there are there are these
different so-called quantum numbers
that determine the characteristics of
which of those electron
energy levels are you dealing with so in
the case of the hydrogen atom there are
three quantum numbers usually called lm
and n
um which determine the uh the basic
which energy level you're talking about
in a hydrogen atom okay that's the
hydrogen atom
let's talk about the helium atom
unbelievably much more complicated
the the whole story of the interaction
between those two electrons
and the possible wave functions that can
occur in with those two electrons
vastly more complicated one of the
things that's really
complicated about it is the thing called
the exclusion principle
that in its simple form just says things
like
electrons kinds of particles like
electrons
not particles like photons but also
particles like protons and so on
electrons have the feature that in
quantum mechanics
if you try and put two of them in kind
of the same energy state
they won't let you do that we actually
think we know why that happens in the
context of our models
and has to do with uh essentially the
failure to merge
different possible histories of the
universe in our multi-weight graphs
um but this that would take a bit of
explanation to to say how that all works
but basically this exclusion principle
has
constraints on the structure of the wave
functions for the helium atom and
they're really complicated
so what happens people have
tried to make solutions for for larger
atoms
and gradually over the decades one's
been getting better and better
at being able to reproduce the energy
levels of even
you know atoms like i don't know gold
atoms or
or things like that gold has a uh um
uh 79 right is gold is it eighty seven
and nine
which one golden mercury one apart i
think i forget 79 i think
um that's the number of um uh how
embarrassing i don't remember that
i do remember tungsten because it's our
alternate name as well from
its element 74 which means it has 74
protons in its nucleus
um but anyway with these with if it has
74 protons in its nucleus
that means that when it's not in any way
ionized
it's sort of natural neutral state it
has 74 electrons
and the interaction between all 74
electrons is unbelievably complicated
and it's been difficult to solve those
equations
and only uh it can only be done with
some degree of approximation
and i'm not sure how accurately all the
energy levels can be reproduced in
something like a tungsten atom now by
the way
one of the things that's coming out of
our models of fundamental physics
is a new way to do those kinds of
computations which looks really
promising
and uh i suspect that it will become
possible to do
sort of quantum mechanical calculations
much more easily as a result of our
models
i'm actually making use of the fact that
our models are fundamentally discrete
they have sort of atoms of space
just like computers fundamentally just
deal with discrete quantities
now the fact is that our atoms of space
are unbelievably tiny
so there are huge numbers of atoms of
space in our real experience of the
universe and of space
but it turns out that by just using that
sort of idea of atoms of space
you can make a scheme for computers to
compute things and they can get pretty
good answers
even when they don't have that many sort
of atoms of space being used
so that's a new sort of method that
we've been developing
uh first for for use in in solving
einstein's equations for gravity
but it also looks very promising as a
way of of
working out things in quantum mechanics
um it's sort of a way of using the
structure of our models
to produce a more efficient way to
compute how things work in the world so
it's possible that there will be changes
in what's what can be done with many
electron
systems of of of heavier atoms
gosh let's see uh
i'm going to do a couple more physics
things and then we'll talk about
something
something different here um oh boy
there's a question from a toray
when an atom absorbs a photon and the
same atom emits a photon
is it the same photon well
when you say two plus two and you get
four
no two plus three you get five you
subtract two again
and you get a three is it the same three
or is it a different three
the answer to that question is the same
answer as the question about photons
really
because essentially what's happening is
that this
this photon is some at least in our
model of physics now
we have some real understanding of this
it's some configuration
of these atoms of space some
connectivity of atoms of space
and that connectivity is destroyed when
the when the photon is absorbed
and then it's recreated when the when
the um
uh when the photon is emitted again now
is it the same one or is it a different
one
i don't know you know it's it's it's
like like is it the same three or not it
doesn't really i think have a
have a clear meaning um and so that
that's uh
uh there isn't really that kind of
identity i mean i think we are used to
the idea that material objects
maintain their identity because they're
just sort of so many
atoms in this material object that they
don't sort of all
transmute in some way at the same time i
mean it's kind of in in philosophy
there's this sort of old story of the
the ship of theseus where you know
there's a ship
it's made from a bunch of planks of wood
and gradually the ship is renovated
one plank has changed another plank has
changed another plank has changed
eventually all the planks have been
changed and then there's a question
is it still the same ship of theseus
even though all the planks have been
changed
that's kind of the same type of question
as we're asking about
electrons or even more extremely about
numbers in that
arithmetic computation
uh
let's see there's a question about uh
from van
about the speed of light
um it's about
how is it an assumption that the one-way
speed of light
how do we measure the speed of light
given that we have to kind of sync up
measurement instruments at the two ends
of the speed of light
well let's see i mean the first way the
speed of light was
measured was very early actually it was
measured in the 1600s
and it was measured by looking at the
moons of jupiter
and so how can you measure the speed of
light from the moons of jupiter
uh here's how so the moons of jupiter
were discovered in 1608 by galileo
and uh what he noticed was that every
few days there are these
uh you know spots of light that um uh be
identified as moons that are going
around jupiter
okay so you assume the moons of jupiter
are going round in a certain orbit
and you assume that um and that then you
have to ask the question um when
the as as the earth goes around its
orbit
the total distance to jupiter changes
and so
the question is if you count the
revolutions
of those some let's see how does this
work you
you're basically measuring the delay
of that orbit as as seen by the earth
when the earth is on one side of its
orbit and when the earth is on the other
side of its orbit
and so you're able to measure the speed
of light by comparing
how much different is that
is the rise time so to speak of let's
say ganymede
relative to what you would expect is the
is the offset of the rise time of
ganymede
um you know as it comes around jupiter
how is that offset
when the earth is on one side of its
orbit as compared to the other side of
its orbit so effectively you're
measuring
the amount of time it takes for light to
cross
the distance that corresponds to the
orbit of the earth so that's the first
way
that um the uh the speed of light was
measured
then within a fairly short amount of
time
50 years maybe maybe 100 years um an
alternative
method was used that involves a toothed
wheel that was rotating very fast
and uh there was uh the question was
you were looking at i guess interference
of light uh with this toothed wheel if
i'm not mistaken
and that's a more direct kind of
terrestrial way to measure the speed of
light
but sort of conceptually the way you
measure the speed of light
is you say you send a light pulse to
somebody
and you you have to there's sort of all
these these kinds of ways to
imagine that you have a sort of lattice
of light pulses
that allows you to define what you mean
by synchronization it's pretty arbitrary
i i noticed for instance you know this
mars lander that just landed a few days
ago
and people were like all you know
cheering on the earth when the mars
lander landed
well were they cheering when the mars
lander landed
or what because the fact is the speed of
light is such that it probably took 20
minutes
for the signal from the lander saying
i've landed
to get to the earth there's a 20-minute
difference
there's a 20-minute time delay
associated with light traveling
so the question is is uh actually more
extremely
if if the spacecraft has
you know a clock on it and the question
is how is that clock synchronized
is noon on the spacecraft synchronized
to noon on the earth or not
well noon on the earth is 20 light
minutes let's say and it's actually
going to vary because the distance
between earth and mars
varies through the year um is so through
multiple years
um is uh uh how is that going to be
synchronized it's sort of arbitrary
how you do that synchronization but it's
perfectly possible
to set up by having sort of a a network
of of light signals being exchanged it's
perfectly possible
to set up a consistent synchronization
of
of uh of of of objects
of events at different times and when
you know that those
individual clocks are running at a
certain speed you can
uh you can you can kind of uh use that
to measure the speed of light
and the speed of light has been measured
very accurately in fact okay this is a
little bit confusing
in the end the speed of light is now in
the system
of units the speed of light is actually
locked to be a particular number
that happened a few years ago and the
reason it works that way
is that uh length and time are related
by the speed of light
and if you you can define time
in term you can define length in terms
of the speed of light
if you know what the time unit is and
you can define time in terms
in terms of length if you know what's
been lighted so the way the the si
system the standard
uh international system of measurement
works
the speed of light was actually locked
at a particular value
and uh i guess it is the
which one is it that's standardized is
it the second or the meter
i don't remember which one is the
fundamental standard
it must be the second because it's done
in terms of the
energy levels of the cesium atom um
and uh so so that
um uh you you've decided what the second
is
and then you just use this fixed number
to determine what the
what the size of the meter is based on
the speed of light so it doesn't
make sense anymore to talk about
measuring the speed of light because
you'd just be changing
the length of the standard meter so to
speak um
that's you you can ask questions about
um how the speed of light
varies the effective speed of light
varies it changes as you change the
gravitational
potential so for example there's a thing
called gravitational redshift
which happens uh well let's not get into
this this is that this is a whole
whole different story um
let's see um
well there's a question from jonas here
what happens when you cool materials
down
um well fundamentally
the thing we have to explain is what is
temperature right so materials are made
of
molecules atoms all bouncing around
the air they're bouncing around in such
a way that
that the you know they keep on colliding
with each other they collide very
frequently in the air
um but they don't stick together they're
they're just
bouncing off and that their their their
um
the the temperature is determining the
average
energy of each molecule and that
determines how fast they're going
and it with the with the parameters of
of
air molecules they don't sort of stick
together and um
the as you decrease the temperature
what you're doing is decreasing the
average energy of every air molecule
which decreases the average speed of the
air molecules
and eventually the air molecules are
moving so sluggishly
that when they they um they can
when they kind of uh uh hit
they will um uh they'll they'll be able
to kind of stick together
and at that point the air will start to
turn into a liquid
and in fact that happens very suddenly
at a very particular
temperature um air will turn into a
liquid just like water
um you can go from steam and at standard
pressure
at 100 degrees centigrade steam will
condense into liquid water
and what's happening there is the at the
lower as you lower the temperature
the average energy of the molecules is
going down
that allows the molecules which have
forces of attraction between them
to kind of latch on to each other and
kind of keep them keep them kind of
clumped together in a liquid
as you lower the temperature even
further in the case of water to zero
degrees centigrade
um you that they'll they'll the the at
the molecules will be sort of
able to the forces of attraction will
overcome
the kind of uh um
the kind of energy that's associated
with temperature
and the molecules will arrange
themselves in a crystal lattice for
example like an ice
so most materials have that feature that
as you cool them down they go from gas
to liquid to solid there's usually
different forms of the solid that can
exist different crystal structures
at different temperatures and pressures
and so on but normally that's the
sequence from
from gas down to liquid down to solid
interesting question whether there can
be more than one liquid phase
whether there can be more than one way
of arranging the atoms
and still have it correspond to a liquid
looks like water may actually be a
combination of two phases
which may explain some of the very very
bizarre features of water
in which it differs from a lot of other
kinds of liquids but be that as it may
the basic sequence is gas liquid to
solid okay so
most materials when you cool them down
far enough they'll eventually turn into
solids
there's only one exception which is
helium
and um when you cool down let's say
hydrogen
you cool it low enough temperature it'll
turn into a solid
you cool air down mixture of nitrogen
and oxygen
uh that the nitrogen oxygen actually
uh become liquids at slightly different
temperatures
minus 1734 degrees centigrade i think
is um uh liquid nitrogen if i remember
correctly
um and um the um so
you keep cooling it down eventually you
get to solid
uh you know sort of solid nitrogen
and that's the end of the story now as a
question
is there a lowest possible temperature
well you might think if the temperature
is the average energy of molecules then
sure there must be a lowest temperature
because the temperature at which there
is no average energy of molecules
molecules just don't have
any kinetic energy they're just kind of
sitting still for example
and yes there is a minimum temperature
it's so-called absolute zero
minus 273.16 degrees centigrade
is absolute zero that's the that's the
temperature which
if you sort of extrapolated from the
energies of molecules that we're used to
that's the temperature at which the
molecules just have no energy
they they have zero energy they kind of
would just be
standing still and so if there's any
force of attraction between the
molecules
that that force of attraction will
overcome anything else and they'll turn
into solids
okay that's the simple picture there's
one
one little glitch in that picture which
is it turns out
nothing ever gets to have actually zero
energy
in quantum mechanics there's a thing
called zero point energy
which is uh means that
everything has these sort of quantized
levels of energy
and that even there's you can't go below
essentially half a unit
of quantized half a quantized unit of
energy and that leads to this phenomenon
of zero point energy
in our models of physics we kind of have
an understanding of where zero point
energy comes from
and actually it's it's closely related
to the way that
space the structure of space is knitted
together if it wasn't for zero point
energy it wasn't for all that activity
happening even in the vacuum
if it wasn't for all of these little
little uh fluctuations even in the
vacuum
space would not be a coherent thing it
wouldn't be the case that we could
have a notion of points in space that
are related to each other and where we
can expect to move
something from one place in space to
another space we just sort of
disintegrated into a bunch of
independent points
that activity that is associated with
zero point energy is actually
uh in our models uh basically the same
phenomenon as the phenomenon that knits
together the structure of space
so but in any case in in um in sort of
everyday quantum mechanics
uh there's this phenomenon of zero point
energy which means that there's
always the molecules never actually get
to stand still they always have a little
amount of energy that's associated with
the so-called vacuum fluctuations there
are a bunch of different ways to
describe it
but it's basically a mathematical
feature of quantum mechanics
and that zero point energy keeps them
wiggling around a little bit
it turns out most materials have enough
force of attraction between the
molecules
or the atoms to overcome that little bit
of wiggling in the zero point energy and
so they become solids at absolute zero
the one exception is helium iv uh the
the isotope of helium that has two
protons two two
uh neutrons in its nucleus that um
uh remains a liquid
at um at absolute zero and now i'm
wondering about helium-3
uh does it remain
helium-3 has very different
characteristics because helium-3
oh this gets us into a different
different whole issue but i talked about
this exclusion principle for electrons
that applies to helium-3 but it does not
apply to helium-4
um uh yeah i think i think
i think helium-4 is i know yeah
i think it does not apply to helium-3 um
so
helium has this feature that even at
absolute zero
the zero-point energy is jiggling around
the helium atoms enough
that they can't form into solid helium
if you put pressure on the helium
then it will indeed form into a solid
but at standard temperature at standard
pressure
one atmosphere you know what we what we
normally have it will not
form into a solid even at absolute zero
so
um
oh boy there's a okay i should i should
probably rap soon here but there's
so many interesting questions here oh
um
it's uh it's a question from b2
about a chap called paul darack who
talked a lot about constants of nature
and uh have we come further in
explaining constants of nature
maybe that's a little bit too
complicated a question that there are
there are some things about
the world like the speed of light uh
planck's constant which is the
the scale that determines quantum
phenomena the gravitational constant
which is the
the the thing that determines the force
of gravity
um there are these various features of
the natural world
many of those features of the natural
world aren't
really things that
they're things that really define the
units of measurement
so i mentioned with the speed of light
the speed of light is really just the
thing that converts
time units to distance units and
similarly some of these other things
like gravitational constant more or less
converts mass units to other things so
if you think you know what a kilogram is
then you can define what the
gravitational constant is but
there are very few kind of the most of
these things are essentially just
definitions
of what the units of mass are what the
units of this are and so on
but there are some combinations of those
constants which are dimensionless
that aren't just definitions of sizes of
units most famous is the thing called
the fine structure constant
has a weird name it arose originally
when people were studying
properties of of atoms and
energy levels of atoms and things but
it's it's
usually written alpha and has a value of
about 1 over 137 point
something or other um and so that
particular
uh constant has been the focus of quite
a lot of activity of can we explain
why the fine structure constant has that
value
well the answer is not yet but
this model of physics that we have
should eventually be able to explain
that
we're not there yet and we don't know
the extent to which
the value of that constant will depend
on
our kind of structure of the way we
describe physics
in fact what seems to be the case in our
models of physics is that
there's just one fundamental universe
but there are different
forms of description of that universe
that give you different physical laws
and so just as the i suspect that the
fine structure constant for example
uh will end up with different values
depending on those different forms of
description and those forms of
description
have to do with saying well are we
describing the universe in terms of
space and time or are we describing it
in terms of some completely other way of
representing the different components of
the universe and that will probably
determine
so the values of those of those
constants and so
they're again as much a reflection of
our way of describing the universe
as they are something fundamental truly
about the universe itself
but they should be things that are
derivable for example in our models
and uh we're not there yet i don't know
how many years it'll be before we are
there
but uh we're definitely on a path that
should allow us to be able to explain
those things
and at least within the context of our
way of describing physics
be able to say oh yes the fine structure
constant is equal to this combination of
pies and
and e's and other mathematical constants
or at least something
that a computer can compute to a high
degree of precision
so that's a thing we hope to be able to
do but um
uh existing physics in the over the last
100 years or so since the fine structure
constant
was was discovered has not really made
much progress
in explaining the value of it
okay maybe one more um
uh oh
i'm too tempted by another physics
question here from
from pass who's asking about what about
the triple point or the critical point
um okay so i
talked about solids liquids gases you
think
you got a solid you know what it is you
got a liquid you know what it is it
pours it it flows
it's hard to squash you know a liquid is
is uh
you can't really compress the liquid too
much and then you have a gas
which you can compress and you say well
those are really distinct things solid
liquid gas
well you can have things a solid can
melt it can turn into a liquid a liquid
can boil it can turn into a gas
a uh there's actually another thing that
can happen which is sublimation
where a solid can turn directly into a
gas that happens with dry ice
solid carbon dioxide for example
at standard pressure and so the question
is are these really all distinct solid
liquid gas
and it turns out that liquid and gas are
not really distinct
so it turns out as you increase pressure
and so on there comes a point at which
the
the molecules are kind of all running
around they're kind of you know they're
kind of clumped together like in a
liquid but they're kind of also
flowing freely like in a gas and they
kind of there comes a point where they
kind of can't really decide whether
they're
a a liquid or a gas and the the line
in in when you when you kind of describe
in the temperature
pressure these temperature pressure
diagrams so-called phase diagrams
that have these lines that separate
things like solid and
liquid and so on um and there's a line
that separates
uh liquid and gas and that line when
it's usually drawn just comes to an end
um that's the critical point that's the
point at which
you can no longer distinguish um between
a liquid and gas they they they have
there's sort of there's a certain amount
of clumping
in the in the solid in the gas that kind
of looks a little bit like pieces of
liquid
and in the liquid there's a certain
amount of things kind of going freely
like in the gas
the critical point is a very interesting
place because it's a place where there's
a sort of hierarchy of different sized
clumps
so there can be a very tiny clump there
can be a very big clump there's a sort
of infinite
uh hierarchy of different sizes of
clumps and so it's a place where if you
were to look at this
this kind of gas or liquid or whatever
it is
at the critical point you would see
these clumps of all sizes
and so if you look at it uh sort of
through at least conceptually through a
microscope
you kind of don't know what the
magnification of that microscope is
because at all scales you will be seeing
clumping going on
and so this is a place where actually it
becomes mathematically
there's some very nice mathematical
features of the critical point
uh leads to a phenomenon uh well
it's so-called renormalization uh it's
the use of realization and condensed
matter physics which is different from
the one in particle physics
although they are connected in various
ways but it's this notion that
the scale doesn't matter it's scale and
variant you can see clumps on all scales
and that allows you to to work out a
bunch of mathematical features
and the kind of the details of the
amount of clumping at each size
are things called critical exponents and
it turns out you can work out those
critical exponents
in a way that's very independent of the
details of the materials
that you're actually looking at and
that's an important sort of thing in
mathematical physics it's kind of a
a big discovery of the oh well i guess
1970s or so
in mathematical physics was the ability
to do things like that
all right maybe one um one last
non-physics question here um
let's see it's a question from ein
uh how would you suggest getting a child
interested in diving deep into science
and technology
not just web programming but something
real what if the kids parents aren't
very interested themselves can the kid
be saved so to speak
you know for example my parents weren't
particularly interested in science
um i got interested in science when i
was really young
and uh i think it's probably even fair
to say that i taught myself to read
from from looking at illustrated science
books where they had you know
captions and you know pictures of things
and and words and so on
so i i suspect i was uh was science
interested
very early for no particularly good
reason
other than that probably it was
not something that parents teachers etc
knew about so i was probably the antsy
example
of um uh you know you you need somebody
who already knows about something
to get you interested in the thing but i
think
uh uh you know the the main
thing i've observed you know i have four
kids
who are terrific but who don't like me
to talk about them at least some of them
don't like me to talk about them
um in these in these public settings uh
sometime i'm going to have to get at
least one or two of my kids to to do one
of these either with me or
or without me um uh they they would uh
they would have a lot of interesting
things to say
but um i would say that
my kids have been uh sort of
variously some of them more interested
some of them less interested in science
and technology
um i think that uh um
my general feeling is that uh
many kids are curious about things and
the question is what
happens to that curiosity is it
does somebody kind of help them figure
out the answer
does somebody tell them oh the answer is
known but you won't understand it
or what happens i think probably the the
answer is known but you won't understand
it
is a pretty guaranteed killer of of that
kind of interest
or at least for many people it would be
um i think
the uh let's go look it up and figure it
out
that's that's probably a good uh a good
approach
um the uh uh i think um
uh that's sort of a good start i think
the
the thing is that sometimes
there's a tremendous tendency on the
part of people who sort of know about
some area of science or tech or whatever
to say to kids you should be interested
in the area that i'm interested in
well depends on the personality of the
kids some kids will be interested in the
exact opposite
of the area you're interested in some
people some kids will be interested more
in the area that you're interested in
um and i think that the uh um
uh the thing that um
um the
the thing to to realize is you know
depending on the age of a kid but
you know the kid is interested in um uh
in something even if you don't think
it's all that interesting
you know go explore it go try and figure
it out
go encourage the kid to go figure it out
even if you think oh that's kind of a
boring thing
um because well among other things
my observation has been that almost any
question
will turn out to be interesting if you
dive deep enough into it
even if it seems like oh that's kind of
obvious that's uh
there's nothing interesting there or
even that question is really hard and
you're not going to be able to figure it
out
well okay you might not be able to
figure it out but you might be able to
figure
out some things that are on the on the
edges of that question
and even the process of figuring things
out is really interesting
i would say that another thing about
science and kids
is for a lot of kids things in science
are just like known by adults and that's
all there is to it
or maybe not known by adults but there's
it's just like it's a cut and dried
thing
and the the process of going from
figuring it out is not something kids
get to see
i mean kids you know will ask their
teachers some question about science or
something the teacher will either say
uh here's the answer or it's not in the
curriculum
or i don't know whatever but the process
of figuring it out
is very rarely visible and i think
that it is super educational when
kids get to see things actually being
figured out i mean that's easier
when it comes to things like
mathematical experiments and so on i
mean i've
done many times i've kind of done live
computer experiments
with kids and and many others um where
sort of the surprising thing
is that you can go from not
understanding something
to having had the computer help you
understand something in a period i don't
know an
hour or whatever and then it's gosh we
figured something out
it's like that's and that's kind of the
the history of science
is a history of people figuring stuff
out but the history of science as told
after the fact
is a story of this was figured out this
was figured out and so on
just sort of the end of the end of each
of those figurings out
of this turned out to be true this
turned out to be true and so on
not really the inner process of what
happened and so i think
that for for kids to see things actually
being made
is is super educational it's educational
for everybody
um and i think uh you know when it comes
to technology
same thing is true you know the thing
that always surprises
people i think is that you know when you
see some piece of software
or something it's just like the thing
just is and the fact that people created
it
and there were decisions to be made
about how did it work and there were
issues of things that
didn't work and they had to be sorted
out and they had to be resolved and so
on
that process is not usually known or
seen by people
and i think when when kids or others
have seen that process and particularly
have seen the process of going from
just an idea to something that really
exists in the world that's a very
that's a very empowering thing to
realize that that happens
and i think that's very motivational in
terms of getting involved with things
like technology
or science if it's a question of
figuring things out in science and so on
i think um uh you know one thing that
can happen in science
is there's a lot to know in science if
you go across sort of all areas of
science
there's just a lot to know and i think
that
you know focusing at any given time on
the one thing that you happen to be
interested in
and not say oh i can't discuss that
because it's a piece of physics
and to understand that piece of physics
you have to have done
uh you know high school physics college
physics graduate school physics
and eventually you'll get to this thing
you're actually interested in that's a
mistake
because there's usually a path that goes
from fairly elementary things to at
least some version
of that thing up in the sky that you're
interested in without having to build
the whole giant framework of all these
different things in the middle in a
sense
my efforts and these q and a's has to do
with finding paths
for to get to the explanation of
something without having to really
explain all of the all of the layers
that exist
and for example early in this q a
somebody was asking about um uh what
size of objects
makes stars as opposed to planets and in
a sense that i was realizing that was
harder for me to explain
than i thought because i you know i know
the official explanations in terms of
you know equations of state of materials
and
you know various kinds of gravitational
instabilities and this and that and the
other
but the question is how much of that
stuff can you unpack
and not have to talk about and still get
to the
the final results and that's sometimes
challenging it sometimes requires
that one understands the stuff really
well in fact that's one of the reasons i
i like doing these q and a's is because
i kind of think i understand stuff like
that
and yet when i come to try to explain it
in these kind of straight lines
without having to go through all these
layers of of um
of of other knowledge um i realize i
don't understand
it quite as well as i thought i
understood it it helps me to try to
try to see that i can make that path um
and get to
and sort of honestly get to the end
without
without really having to say anything
that you know saying things which are
which uh if you were to know all of that
graduate school physics and say yeah
that's right
but still not have to know all that
graduate school physics to to get there
so well
somebody parmenides is commenting surely
my kids are more likely to embarrass me
rather than the other way around i
my kids are wonderful and they they
would be very um
uh um yeah well you you guys should um
uh particularly one of them i i would
love to persuade to do
live streams like this them they would
uh they would
be able to talk about some super
interesting things very different
from the kinds of things that i talk
about um and uh
yeah well okay i think i should um
uh wrap up at this point before i get
myself in any more trouble
um but uh
um yeah lots lots of interesting
questions we'll
we'll save them up from next time next
time and um
uh well uh thanks for for joining us
and